euh
et la mosaïque ici c'est le feu la façon dont
les femmes sont tuées, euh c'était par
strangulation puis par brûlure donc la
mosaïque dénote le fait qu'elle a été
brûlée comme sorcière pour se débarrasser de ses cendres
[Musique]
on sent que c'était un
chose absolument terrible qui s'est produite dans
l'histoire de l'Écosse, c'était une erreur
judiciaire à cette époque, les gens croyaient
vraiment très fort au diable, ils avaient
vraiment l'impression d'opérer dans un
monde dans lequel le diable était là pour
les avoir et les femmes étaient des vaisseaux faibles.
par qui le diable pouvait-il agir,
c'est pourquoi les femmes avaient tendance à
être accusées parce que les femmes étaient considérées
comme quelqu'un que le diable pouvait
manipuler facilement alors que les hommes pouvaient
résister, vous savez, les avances du diable
[Musique] [
Musique]
nous sommes là
et malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas  un
problème terminé, il y a encore des personnes à travers
le monde généralement vulnérables, souvent des
femmes ou des personnes âgées qui sont
accusées de sorcellerie et, dans certains cas,
tuées par la justice populaire.